Yes, this is very beautiful.
We talked about it in an earlier video
pandigital numbers. And a pandigital number
a number that used all digits, from one
to nine. And we had ... [Brady]: And zero?
[James]: Zero was not always used, I think sometimes
excluded zero and sometimes used zero
and you get different numbers with
different properties and we had
enjoyment of pandigital numbers
It was fun
[Brady]: Yes, it's there. People can click on it.
[James]: There?
[Brady]: Er ... Yes! About there. Right.
[James]: Now I want to show you a pandigital formula
So that is a formula that uses all numbers,
1 to 9. And it is actually very beautiful
Let me write down the formula.
(1 + 9 to power, I will use -4
up to 6 times 7, all in between
brackets, and then I raise that to a power
and that is 3 to the power 2 to
the power 85. So this is the formula,
Let's check if it's a pandigital formula
let's see if all the numbers are there
We have 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9 -
Yes. I have used all numbers from 1 to 9.
But what's so special about that formula?
He is very nice.
This formula is equivalent to 2.718281828 ...
... 459 ...
This formula is actually ... e.
It's about e. How about then?
How good is he?
This is correct to 18 trillion trillion
numbers, decimals. [Brady]: NO! Go away!
[James]: Yes, I know, it's great. This beautiful one
small formula is incredibly precise for e
[Brady]: How is that possible?
[James]: It's beautiful! I'll tell you how that is possible.
This formula is not
very old. He was discovered in 2004
by someone named Richard Sabey, and he
did something very clever about this one
formula because the definition of e,
It is the limit for n going to infinity of
(1 + 1 / n) to the power n.
Now he did something smart. He found one
number that I call capital letter N.
And that's a big number. Actually
this thing we have here.
This power. So he had a 3 to power
2 to power 85 and he did something smart.
I'm gonna juggle a little with this
and I hope you understand
how powers work, because I use
certain characteristics of how powers work, and
this is what i am going to do. I'm going
take one of these 85 and me
use that to squeeze the 3. So it
now becomes 9 to power 2 to power 84
and now I'm going to do something smart
if you understand how powers work
this is also 9. I am going to do that
2 there double, that becomes a 4. And 84
is cut in half, and thus becomes 42. These are all
properties of powers, and I go
split the 42. This becomes 9 to power
4 to power 6 times 7, because that is 42.
If I put a minus sign there, it becomes
the 1 divided by N. So, what he has now is
a formula of this form: (1 + 1 / N)
to the power N - but this N is huge.
This is a huge number, it's so big
that it is an incredibly exact
approach provides for e. Not infinite, it doesn't work
to infinity and is exactly e.
It's big enough for something
that is correct up to 18 trillion
trillion digits. There was a challenge - it was
a kind of challenge on it
internet - as a challenge he thought:
I'm going to think about this. For the same
He actually came up with competition
a number of formulas, and he went by
the classical mathematical constants, so he
did e, and e is the best, and I love e so much.
But he also did pi and others.
I'll show you that for Pi - I don't find it
so beautiful, i don't like it very much, it is
handsome that he
it has done with a pandigital formula, but
I'll show you why he's not so good.
So he has a formula for pi, and that is
approximately equal to -
and this is him - it is 2 to the power 5 to the power, 4
-, 6 min, and by the way here, we have, 3 to the power 9
divided by 7. And then we take that whole
and raise it to power
, 8, to power, 1
[Brady]: Yes, there are many commas.
[James]: Many commas. And instead of saying 0.6
and 0.1 he uses a comma. He plays
maybe false, I don't know, by none
use zeros, I am not so satisfied with it.
This is exact for pi to ten decimal places.
It is much less impressive,
so you have a pandigital formula for that
pi, for 10 decimal places, with a bit of cheating,
I don't know, it depends how you
think about it - commas use something instead of zero
I don't like that formula very much.
[James from "Pandigital Numbers"]: And that's a number that
can also be divided by 10, and that too
is unique, so that would be unique
pandigital number with zero.